on high streets the grip of coronavirus
is tightening measures to contain the
health emergency choking off Britain's
economy a string of major retailers and
household names announcing they would
close before the government forced their
hand leaving usually thriving town
centers to the needy the curious and
those who may have nowhere else to go in
Oxford's covered market independent
traders are preparing for the worst
of course I'm self-employed and will
have no income until this is all over so
that's something I've got to address
myself obviously but the first priority
is is RT we will have a business we've
built our business up over 35 years and
people will come back for us
we're in the in the rateable value for
government grants we know that we will
have be assisted with our staffs
salaries for up to 80% I am an optimist
I think that things can only get better
essential services are the exception to
the shutdown bombers greengrocers has
been transformed almost overnight from a
family market stall to a crucial home
delivery business people need food now
so we're just trying to fill the gap
we're trying to reach everyone
overnight we lost our wholesale business
because the college's shirts the
restauranteur shirts
everything's gone and I've got people
crying on the phone I'm not just getting
an order email I'm getting a two three
four paragraph of this is my situation I
have nothing I have no one football in
High Street is already down 40% retail
analysts say force closure will have an
even more dramatic impact around 80
percent in Italy so they did see a
massive sweep downwards once people were
just not allowed to go out so the only
thing you'll be able to buy here will be
essentials and while not everyone is
heeding the request to stay at home you
can feel the life being squeezed out of
the streets and the city the challenge
for the government is to support
businesses large and small and their
employees as we are asked to abandon
them among the latest measures the
effective national ization of the
railways to insulate franchises from a
massive reduction in services
in every corner of the economy people
are now looking to the state to ensure
they and their families stay afloat Paul
Kelso Sky News in Oxford